[Music]
yeah I wanted to have you on the first
week of shows I know I was supposed to
be here but I got um I got menitis and I
was in the hospital for like five days
menitis menitis it sounds like Robin
Hood
menitis yes it sounds that way
rhythmically you said that with such
such disdain well I mean as someone who
went through menitis you're like yes
rhythmically correct yeah yeah guess
that's a great
pun about a condition you you suffered
yes I suffered through it it's it's uh I
don't know if anyone um knows about it
or or how or anyone currently have
currently have menag uh but basically
it's like it it it's it's a flu like
thing that you get and and most people
have it they don't even know they like
sweat it out go back to work the next
day yeah for like a very small
percentage it gets it it it gets in your
spine and your brain and and swells your
brain up is that what happened to you
that's what happened to me you got brain
swell I got brain swell I got the brain
fever you got that brain flu yeah and it
was crazy it was like I I don't remember
a ton of it when it was going on but I
remember going to the hospital and you
know they do that like rundown check
with you where they're like do you smoke
and I was like no I don't smoke and
they're like do you drink and I was like
no I don't drink and they're like do do
you do anything and like for some reason
I was like I'm a marijuana
Enthusiast and it's on the clipboard
marijana like like as if I'm like
running for the green party or
something like the guy looked at me like
what does that mean and I had to go oh I
I smoke weed every day multiple times a
day but that doesn't have anything to do
with brain no that has nothing to do
with it in fact they they say that that
um helps ease the symptoms or or I The
Chronic I say that now yeah um but no no
it has nothing to do with it uh they
they do think that there's like a thing
where you I possibly could have gotten
it for from eating my kids
just is that
oversharing like I guess look at
that oh
man this is when we pull out the scripts
that reveal Every Beat was planned yeah
we wrote this whole thing yeah uh and
the whole audience is my
family tell me tell me uh tell me why
you would eat uh your child well I I
mean I I uh I don't do it like
recreationally it's not like it's not
like a a great dish or anything yeah
like you're not one of those crazy
parents that even his is great no
[Music]
no